allow me to quote myself Gavin Newsom is
an evil soulless devil worshiper uh yeah
that's the only way I can put it uh he
kept the schools closed he destroyed the
economy of California hundreds of
thousands of people have fled he is the
number one U-Haul uh rental sales guy in
the country because all sorts of people
like me oh and her and this guy and that
guy everyone in this room and a couple
people downstairs right now all fled we
were all uh good tax paying citizens of
California and we all got out of that
dystopian nightmare uh to move to the
free state of Florida because of this
guy and now his wife's freaking parents
are donating to the guy that he hates
most but what else has Gavin Newsom done
I mean he's always saying the nice
things he puts a lot of gel in his hair
he must be doing something good for that
state well here's what's going on over
in L.A in Los Angeles County more than
60 000 people are homeless on the
average night and more than twenty
thousand hotel rooms lie empty on the
average night
see where this might be going it's just
it's insane
um it it isn't going to solve the
problem we think this is one part of the
solution by no means do we think this
solves a homelessness crisis but do
hotels have a role to play of course
they do so the union he leads which
wraps hotel workers gathered enough
signatures and angelinos will vote on a
bill that would force every hotel and
town to report vacancies at 2PM every
day then welcome homeless people into
those vacant rooms honestly would you
check into a hotel knowing that the
chance of your neighbor
to the left or right is a homeless
individual Manaj Patel voluntarily rents
some rooms to homeless people who are
vetted and paid for by a local church
but he's against this bill that would
make that mandatory we barely are
surviving number one number two we have
to think of the safety of our staff and
number three we're not professionally or
any other ways equipped with any of the
supporting mechanism that the homeless
guest would require what services would
be provided remains unclear also unclear
the funding and hotels would be paid
fair market rate opponents of housing
the homeless and hotels fear this and
fear tourists could be put off from even
coming to La I wouldn't want my kids
around people that I'm not sure about I
wouldn't want to be in an elevator with
somebody who's clearly having a mental
break the idea that you can intermingle
homeless folks with paying normal
gas it just doesn't work out we don't
want to head backwards into the
segregated South but that's kind of the
language that they're talking about
there's a certain class of people less
than humans animals they almost describe
mess to be honest with you they don't
seem to understand who the unhoused are
we're talking and about seniors students
working people that's who the voucher
program would benefit the most oh my God
the hotels have some role to play in
this of course homeless people should
have room service filet mignon and
massages
God these people have that in L.A have
that at California that's your mayor
these are the people you voted in enjoy
it you freaks but what else is going on
in Cali man I'm in a good mood today
here a little more you know what
fifteen dollars fifteen American dies
it's only worth seven dollars now thanks
to Joe Biden that's going right in the
jar right there okay uh what else is
going on in California well the place is
burning down and they don't have any
energy here's a quote from Bloomberg
California narrowly avoided implementing
rotating outages on Monday while
officials warned that the state's power
grid will face a bigger test on Tuesday
that's tomorrow amid a record-breaking
Heat Wave no that's today sorry the
state's grid operator canceled its Grid
Emergency late Monday evening after
deploying supplies that helped keep the
lights on even as electricity use soared
to its highest level in five years the
prospect of outages underscores how
grids have become vulnerable in the face
of extreme weather as they transition
from fossil fuels to renewable energy
California has aggressively closed
natural gas power plants in recent years
leaving the state increasingly dependent
on solar Farms that go dark late in the
day just as electricity demand Peaks at
the same time the state is in during its
worst drought in 1200 years sapping
hydropower production so people need
more power at night for AC they're
turning on lights etc etc and you're not
going to believe this solar power
needs that light that thing up there
that people used to worship the sun
these people are all backwards morons
complete idiots all of Laguna Beach okay
Laguna Beach one of the most beautiful
places in the United States their power
grid went out yesterday for seven hours
it's one of the richest places I've been
to Laguna to some fancy freaking houses
with some rich people but Rich morons at
this point if they still live in Laguna
Beach restaurants lost power grocery
stores lost power
etc etc so have at it